[Musique]
Chantal Hébert Véronique prince Michel
David bonsoir
quand on lit je vais vous montrer la
citation du rapport du Protecteur du
citoyen qui s'adresse à des blancs à un
ministère un ministre les pratiques
constatées constituent un grave cas de
mauvaise gestion on a appris après qu'il
s'agissait du ministère de l'éducation
d'un différent entre le ministère et le
cabinet du ministre qui lui voulait
financer je vous le montre rapidement
entre autres le Club des petits
déjeuners mais ne passait pas par les
normes enfin selon les pratiques que le
ministère souhaitait fiducide
l'éducation à Dieu première nation à nos
profs Véronique ça ça sable on se dit
bon ben ça y est il y a une grosse
histoire à Québec
où vous en êtes dans votre compréhension
de ça maintenant
en fait je pense qu'on a vu un côté
pervers peut-être de la loi facilitant
la divulgation d'actes répréhensible à
l'égard des organismes publics pourquoi
parce que le Protecteur du citoyen a
déclenché une enquête sur la base d'une
dénonciation anonyme ne révèle pas le
ministre le ministère qui visait ni le
moment des faits parce qu'on veut pas
être en mesure de pouvoir identifier le
plaignant par exemple ça a ses vertus
évidemment mais dans un cas comme
celui-là que pensez-vous qu'il est
arrivé à Québec là tout le monde était
au téléphone cet après-midi même vous
patriez on essayait tous de savoir mais
de quel ministre il s'agit et là je peux
vous dire que tous les noms y ont passé
là alors tout le monde est devenu
suspect finalement dans cette
histoire-là et évidemment le réflexe
c'est de penser que si le gouvernement
le goût qui visait parce que c'est lui
qui est là depuis les quatre dernières
années mais en fin de compte on
s'aperçoit à la fin de la journée que
non c'est un ministre libéral alors ça
devenait gênant même pour le Parti
libéral de la vente dénoncé exactement
Chantal Michel gardez vos ce que envie
de dire parce qu'on va écouter la
réaction monsieur le Tanguay ce matin
qui dit ben voilà la preuve qu'il est
kakis sont des patients on écoute
et là vous dites quel sera le peut-être
le talon d'Achille du gouvernement qui
est devant nous ça commence pas mal et
un talon d'Achille ça l'éthique ce
gouvernement là on a quelques noms en
tête mais je me réserverai parce que
j'ai pas évidemment on a tous les mêmes
noms en tête mais j'ai pas les fait
c'est sous les libéraux on apprend après
la plaie Michel David il y a un côté il
loufoque peut-être qu'un fond très
préoccupant mais à côté loufoque
arrosé il a vraiment monsieur Tanguy qui
déchire sa chemise et là on se rend
compte que il y a finalement à compter
dans son propre but mais d'un
gouvernement à l'autre on se rend compte
quand même qu'il y a des choses qui
changent pas beaucoup parce que cette
histoire-là me fait beaucoup penser à ce
que la vérificatrice générale avait
découvert l'an dernier à propos de
Pierre fait du Gabin ça se ressemble
beaucoup et à ce moment-là il y avait eu
68 millions je pense de subventions qui
avaient été accordée à des entreprises à
l'encontre des recommandations des
fonctionnaires
une rencontre des normes qui avaient
établies et là me suffisamin avait dit
bah oui mais je fasse l'énorme peuvent
pas tout prévoir puis moi et évidemment
on se demandait tous c'était pas encore
des amis de Monsieur fait du Québec et
lui disait ben écoutez je connais tout
le monde de toute façon alors il y a
quelque chose ou il y a des normes où il
y en a pas il y a des des entreprises ou
des organismes qui voyant les normes ne
demandent pas de subventions et un autre
se fout d'énormes et les obtient alors
là il y a quelque chose qui qui est
inéquitable mais c'est Chantal Hébert le
fond du débat ici c'est à dire les est
un fonctionnaire qui s'est plaint donc
les fonctionnaires disent vous pouvez
pas cabinet ou ministre faire ceci parce
que nous on juge que c'est pas approprié
puis ça ça ne ce n'est pas pas assez par
les critères que qui existent dans le
cas de tel programme ou telo ça donc
c'est qui du politique ou de la machine
dans un cas comme ça peut avoir le
dessus
bon deux choses d'abord je vais revenir
sur le Parti libéral c'est la deuxième
fois que Monsieur Tanguay tire plus vite
que son ombre et les deux fois il s'est
tiré dans le pied alors il y a une leçon
là quand même il s'appelle en
journaliste en anglais on se dit donc
lettre de fax Catherine Story c'est
toujours mieux d'attendre les faits sur
ce que vous venez de mentionner
en principe oui c'est beau d'avoir un
système de plainte mais si ça prend
quatre ans pour avoir le résultat et que
ça te permet même plus du gouvernement
qui est en place là il y a un problème
systémique pour utiliser un mot que le
gouvernement de François degault aime
pas beaucoup c'est à dire la
vérificatrice générale
un an arrive à des conclusions sur un
ministre qui est en poste mais mais là
on est en train de parler d'une enquête
commençait en 2018 sous un ancien
gouvernement dont on obtient les
résultats aujourd'hui je vous dirais que
c'est pas particulièrement efficace oui
et Véronique et Michel c'est Sébastien
prout qui était à la tête du ministère
de l'éducation qui lui voulait donner de
l'argent donc au club du petit déjeuner
à ceci à cela puis les fonctionnaires
ont dit ben vous pouvez pas il a dit oui
je peux c'est ça aussi qui est en jeu là
Véronique oui parce qu'en fait on
jugeait ici dans cette enquête là qui
avait probablement une relation de
proximité entre l'organisme et Sébastien
prout des membres de son cabinet qui a
fait en sorte que cette organisme là
plus qu'un autre a été favorisé mais
entre vous et moi Mark Tanguy il est
sorti sur l'heure du dîner pas tellement
longtemps après le communiqué de presse
du Protecteur du citoyen c'était le
dernier moment de la journée où il était
visible j'ai un petit peu l'impression
quand même que le gouvernement le Go
c'est gâté plus tard en après-midi ils
veulent savoir ce qui va parfait on va
leur
n'était plus visible du reste de la
journée parce que je peux vous assurer
qu'on aurait essayé de lui parler dans
les corridors
[Musique]
un
scandale c'est quoi le titre excusez-moi
Marc Tanguay dénonce un scandale libéral
ça c'est comme ça bon ok Michel un petit
mot sinon je passe à la deuxième sujet
il y a un problème quand même parce que
les petits déjeuners ou une entreprise X
ou Y peut très bien avoir mérité une
subvention correspond pas aux normes
pour toutes sortes de raisons alors il y
a un problème de bureaucratie un moment
donné là qui doit pas empêcher disons
les bonnes actions ouais on imagine
qu'il faut quand même que des garde-fous
parce qu'il parle de proximité mais à sa
façon même ce sont des organismes qui
les l'aide aux devoirs puis les petits
déjeuners bon ça peut être utile aussi
la représentation des parties Véronique
lossa chicane pas à peu près le Parti
québécois a envoyé des dessins
qui montrerait avec l'offre qui est
actuellement sur la table ça continue à
négocier le nombre de questions on va
voir ça à l'écran le nombre de questions
qu'ils auraient par cycle de 5 questions
le PQ on aurait 5 ils ont trois députés
je vous le rappelle les libéraux 70
Québec solidaires 25 qui dit ça pas de
bon sens et là le budget de
fonctionnement c'est aussi c'est en
négociation parce que je rappelle
Mesdames et Messieurs que le Parti
québécois n'est pas reconnu comme un
parti officiel n'ayant que trois députés
là on leur offrirait presque 500 000
isendements de 800 000 ça c'est une
point de départ Véronique ou ce que ça
va s'améliorer dans la perspective du PQ
et des autres parties ou pas en fait la
raison pourquoi le Parti québécois sort
sur la place publique aujourd'hui alors
que ça fait des jours qu'on essaie de
savoir ce qu'il négocie et c'est le
silence radio chez tous les partis là ça
ça veut dire que ça n'avance plus l'on
doit être probablement rendu à un point
mort des négociations puis on se disent
ben on rien à perdre on va sortir ça
publiquement pour montrer qu'on est
mécontent Québec solidaire de son côté
dit on est prêt à avoir une
reconnaissance du chef possiblement un
leader parlementaire mais plus que ça là
c'est un petit peu trop parce que faut
quand même pas oublier qu'ils sont trois
parce que quoi dit oui mais attention
nous ce qu'on aimerait qu'il soit
reconnu c'est pas seulement le nombre de
députés mais le pourcentage d'appui et
ça on devrait être pratiquement égaux
parce que en campagne on s'est aperçu
qu'ils avaient pratiquement le même
pourcentage d'appui ce qui est difficile
ici là c'est que Québec solidaire
compare à sa situation d'il y a quelques
années quand eux ils étaient trois et
que c'était Françoise David qui était
chef eux disent ben nous on avait
accepté de pas avoir eu de
reconnaissance la différence c'est qu'à
ce moment-là qu'avec solitaire était
plus marginal je dirais comme partie
tandis que l'on a une situation où on a
le Parti québécois qui depuis toujours
en fait depuis longtemps je dirais et
reconnu et l'autre doit gérer une
décroissance et ça fait terriblement mal
de perdre des acquis qu'ils ont depuis
tellement Chantal on imagine qu'ils vont
à perdre ils auront pas tout ce qu'ils
veulent c'est à peu près sûr non mais
eux calculs qui vont avoir plus que ce
qu'ils ont expliqué en allant sur la
place publique et c'est là qu'ils sont
rendus cela dit à la fin le nombre de
députés à son importance demandée
pas de droit de parole pas de budget
pour rien donc
et
le particulier a été au gouvernement
plusieurs fois depuis
1976 a promis de changer du système
électoral c'est pas un parti comme
Québec solidaire qui est arrivé
récemment que jamais eu le pouvoir et
qui a pris des décisions en fonction des
autres qu'aujourd'hui il n'aime pas en
fonction de lui-même Michel ouais ben
écoutez au lendemain d'élection tout le
monde a dit que le mode de scrutin
entraînait les dysfonctions qui étaient
de moins en moins acceptable étant donné
la multiplication des parties le partage
du temps le partage de l'enveloppe entre
les parties de position et fonction de
ce mode de scrutin dysfonctionnel alors
je comprends très bien la colère du PQ
qui ont plus de votes en proportion que
les libéraux et qui ont à peu près 9
fois moins de budget et de questions
alors il y a certainement quelque chose
qui qui marche pas là-dedans je
comprends que la tradition veut que ça
soit fonction du nombre de députés tout
ça mais en réalité politique et que ce
système là fait en sorte que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui à travers les
parties pour lesquelles sont votés se
trouvent pénalisés dans leur capacité de
poser des questions au gouvernement mais
comme Chantal en même temps à ce
compte-là les conservateurs à nos héros
absolument et imaginez s'il fallait que
s'il y avait eu un député avec 13% du
vote la chicane aurait été encore plus
grande
c'est pas parce que il y a de s'arrêter
pire que ce qui est là est bon je pense
qu'il y a un problème et est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer des solutions est-ce que
les libéraux et la CAQ vont être encore
plus magnanime et essayer d'adopter
quelque chose qui va plaire à tout le
monde c'est possible ça mais d'abord
c'est d'abord un problème entre les
parties d'opposition pour ce qui est du
temps de parole la CAQ va pas donner son
temps de parole manifestement à la
période des questions qu'est-ce que ils
sont de l'autre côté de la chambre je
suis pas convaincu qu'il va y avoir une
immense générosité pour la bonne et
simple raison qu'en politique
les retours d'ascenseur ou le nom retour
d'ascenseur sont la règle rappelez-vous
à Ottawa quand le Bloc québécois est
tombé en dessous de la ligne ils ont eu
aucune aide pour avoir plus de temps de
parole pourquoi parce qu'il l'avait
refusé au MPD une certaine époque alors
je vois pas moi comment on peut demander
aux parties d'opposition de régler le
problème du mode de scrutin à l'interne
et j'y crois pas vraiment
très bien alors on suivra ça non il y
avait les extraits on suivra ça mais on
va écouter quand même c'est intéressant
les entendre on les a pas entendus plus
haut à l'émission faire ce nom c'est en
game sur le duc sur cette question là
puis on vient tout de suite
ne suivent pas les balises et surtout ce
qu'on refuse de faire évoluer
l'institution dans le sens du
multi-partisme où on a essentiellement
une triple légalité j'ai parti
d'opposition et puis quand on dit que la
règle c'est faire élire 12 députés ou
obtenir 20% des voix il y a deux
facteurs il y a celui du nombre de
députés puis le nombre de voix obtenues
à l'heure actuelle le nombre de voix
obtenu là il est complètement éliminé ça
ne fait plus partie de l'équation vous
représentez que vous-même
essentiellement
déclare que le Parti québécois va finir
avec quelque chose de plus que trois
indépendants en termes notamment de
droit de parole
je commencerai pas là dessus ils font
leur demande ils font leur demande puis
c'est tout à fait légitime alors place
je partirai probablement avec les mêmes
demandes maintenant ça fait partie des
discussions
dites-vous une chose à la fin de la
journée personne n'aura obtenu tout tout
tout tout ce qui ne m'a
s d'accord qui en reconnaissent la
chefferie du Parti québécois après ça
sur tous les tenants aboutissants le
budget les questions les discussions
sont pas terminées ça progresse je pense
que le Parti québécois a encore le temps
de tirer son épingle du jeu maintenant à
étaler tout ça sur la place publique là
c'est du stratégie que moi je n'ai pas
envie d'adopter bon petit message ici si
vous voulez qu'on reçoit plus jeune
s’arrêter dans d'envoyer les petits
graphiques ok
Jean-François nous disait tout à l'heure
sur cette rencontre un peu surréaliste
hier mais ce qui se réalise c'est qu'il
y a eu un micro une caméra entre le
président chier et Justin Trudeau disait
sur les relations canadachines lui
disait c'est un impair du point de vue
des Chinois ça va pas aider à court
terme sur le plan de la politique
intérieure Chantal est-ce que Monsieur
Trudeau a pas marqué des points face au
conservateur qui effectivement lui
disait parler lui parlez lui de
l'ingérence chinoise par exemple
si ce soir on est en train de discuter
du fait que Monsieur Trudeau a croisé
trois fois plus tôt qu'une le président
chinois et qu'il ne lui a pas adressé la
parole pour lui dire
sur fond de de reportage qui disent il y
a eu de l'ingérence politique dans la
dernière campagne électorale on a arrêté
quelqu'un qui travaille à Hydro-Québec
présumément parce que la Chine aurait
donné là-dedans donc monsieur Trudeau
viendrait il y aurait parlé à personne
et il y aurait rien dit il serait
effectivement en bien moins bonne
posture qu'après avoir eu cet échange là
deuxièmement oui j'ai entendu
Jean-François d'épine parler d'un père
au sujet de la conversation mais en
temps de nous le monsieur Trudeau son
bureau jamais rendu public la réponse du
président chinois il a le bureau du
premier ministre a fait état des actes
du Premier ministre du Canada ce qui
normalement comme journaliste fait
partie des choses auxquelles on
s'attendre quand on couvre un sommet
avec le Premier ministre y est il y a
pas dit et il m'a répondu ou voici ce
qu'il m'a dit ou dans le fond il est
d'accord qu'il faut c'est pas arrivé ces
choses là alors quelque part j'ai
l'impression moi que Justin Trudeau à la
fin et plus satisfait que l'inverse de
ce qui s'est passé
vous les avez vu les mêmes courriels que
moi à un moment donné la question qui se
pose de plus en plus et est-ce qu'on
doit s'excuser de notre premier ministre
parce que un dictateur lui a dit de pas
partager des informations sur ce qu'il
fait comme premier ministre un sommet
est-ce que vous dites une image qui
porte c'est s'imaginer
s'il ne l'avait pas croisé du tout qui
lui avait pas parlé du tout puis revient
au Canada après la francophonie un jour
là il serait fait poser des questions
par Monsieur poillert Michel
capacez-vous ben je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec avec Chantal monsieur
Trudeau ne pouvait pas ne pas en parler
à partir du moment où il y avait une
rencontre avec avec le Président si et
il y a rien d'anormal là-dedans de tout
temps quand un premier ministre canadien
se promène dans des forums
internationaux c'est presque une figure
imposée que de dire à gouvernement un
interlocuteur totalitaire nous ça nous
préoccupe la question des droits de
l'homme je pense que ça si Monsieur
Trudeau c'était limité à ça monsieur
hausser les épaules là l'ingérence il y
a pas aimé ça de tout évidence et je
pense pas que les Canadiens qui qui
suivent ça puis qui découvrent
apparemment il y a des postes de police
chinois à Toronto je sais pas exactement
ce qui en retourne mais il est clair
qu'un premier ministre canadien peut pas
faire semblant qui se passe rien et
Monsieur Trudeau a été quand même
chanceux je pense que Monsieur que
Monsieur TSI se fâche parce que une
caméra
parce qu'autrement finalement il serait
revenu en disant oui j'ai dit j'ai dit
mais là on a la preuve que ça a marché
parce qu'on a la preuve qu'il a un
disposé puis j'en fais ça parlait plus
de l'axe Chine Canada disposé le géant
chinois là qui
vous regardez un jeu je suis pas content
il est pas content bon ver je le disais
j'ai reçu plein de courriels de gens
depuis hier qui me disait moi j'aime pas
nécessairement monsieur Trudeau mais là
il y a mis ses culottes et puis bravo
etc donc en fait si Justin Trudeau
n'avait pas parlé de ça avec le
dirigeant chinois probablement que ça
aurait davantage mini peut-être sa
mission parce que moi je me rappelle
d'une mission économique de Philippe
Couillard en Chine justement il me
semble que c'était en 2014 je me
rappelle bien en 2016 puis à ce
moment-là il avait rencontré justement
des ministres chinois il avait rencontré
plusieurs dirigeants il ne leur avait
pas parlé de la question des droits de
l'homme et justement sa mission après ça
va être tournée autour de ça à chaque
fois qu'il sortait en point de presse on
lui rappelait qu'ils n'avait pas abordé
cette question là ça lui avait plus fait
mal qu'autre chose très bien alors vous
êtes il leur est chorégraphié le récurer
a fait pas mal comme ça très bien merci
beaucoup à vous trois et là je le disais
c'est pas fini allez les pecs où il
pourrait le recroiser ensuite c'est
Tunisie francophonie soit on va en
parler de la prochaine fois de la
ensemble merci à très bientôt au revoir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI